Speaker 1: Let's try Carl from California,
Carl from California.
You were on the air.
Speaker 2: Hello.
Yeah, so how are you?
Although I was wondering how is the cope is
not was planning on going to a specific date
of and, you know, covid numbers are supposed
to like, calm down, are they going down?
I don't really know too much about this.
Speaker 1: They are going down.
Yes.
So cases are down about 85 percent from the
peak and declining deaths are down about 82
percent from the peak and declining.
Speaker 2: Yeah, about that.
I was just wondering, is Donald Trump planning
on going for reelection and what do you think?
Do you think he can make it?
Speaker 1: I don't think we will know until
we see the twenty, twenty two results.
And what I mean by that, Karl, is Donald Trump
wants to be the kingmaker in twenty, twenty
two.
He wants to decide who are the good Republicans
and who are the bad Republicans and who gets
reelected.
And because of the decision made about did
you see what happened with Liz Cheney earlier
this week, Liz Cheney, the Republican congresswoman,
was stripped of her leadership role by Republicans.
I don't know if you heard about that.
Speaker 2: Yeah, sorry, here's one more thing.
Speaker 1: Oh, I haven't even answered the
question yet, Carl, but we can move on.
It sounds like you have a big agenda to get
to.
Speaker 2: Are sorry, this is something that
I was actually came here for.
Oh, OK.
So you had a video and it said Biden hits
are sixty three approval, right?
Sixty three percent of approval.
Yes.
And one of my friends said that was like,
I'm not correct.
Like it was done.
The polls were like specifically biased for
the Democratic Party.
How were they do.
Once again.
Speaker 1: Take your time, Carl, please.
Speaker 2: The.
Speaker 1: Ouf, are you lifting weights?
I hope you are OK.
All right.
All right, Carl, thank you for the call.
We'll see you.
I mean, it's just it's off the rails, guys,
that will publish that because it's funny,
but that.
Don't don't be Carl.
Don't
be Carl.